Hello everybody, My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to "Lethe", now this is a
save point I knew this, I knew this
before, and I even saw this particular
save point in the last game that I played,
but to get to it you needed to go to the
side here
crawl-through, wait no not here. Here?
oh it's closed down now but you need to
go to the side and crawl through a tiny
crawl space over here so that you get to
it, and there's a bear trap right
there I don't know how I didn't touch
that one there are a lot of bear traps
just lurking in the darkness
I don't know why and I don't know where
but they're going to find me and they're
going to bite me in the butt so I
finally saved and apparently the
developers even said this this is the
only way you can save minus a few level
transition auto-saves now I don't really
like that I made my case in the last
episode but I can't fault them for me
not doing the mechanics I wasn't aware
that I needed to go through secret path
when I saw that I thought the ladder up
might have got me there and the
drop-down seemed like it might have
dropped down into this point where the
save point was so I - I want to kind of
apologize for coming down heavy handed, but I kinda don't because it's kind of
little bit mehhh
but anyway, "I was naive back then her
husband Jake was ferocious beyond
compare
but foolish as I was I kept pushing my
luck",
"the man was of great influence on the
village silent whispers described him as
a merciless man", " we had no other choice
but have our meetings in utmost secrecy
but it ,wasn't long enough, but it wasn't
enough
our hearts kept longing for more and so
we became lovers".
well this is an interesting tale of
adultery but oh well, also I had to go
down here and replace it was a puzzle in
and of itself had to go down there get a
power supply and put it back up here and
find a way to get back up So, with all
that being said we have made progress we
are going forward and now I need to go
back because i need to go up the ladder
over here, and this ladder you can see
how I might have been misled into
thinking that this was going to go up
and then drop down into that room
because it looked like it was gonna to
because I was going over here in this
seemed, oh yeah this was the bear trap
room, I didn't remember I hit them all
over again because I'm a big dumb fool,
and then coming over, like in my
mind this was kinda close to where that
room was but apparently not and I am
forlorn and I have to go through this
again but the reason I'm starting here
now is because i have done the save and
that way if I die on this chase that's
about to happen, it won't be the end of
the world, it will be the end of my world
and i'll be very upset but it won't be
the end of The world
yes that's good okay so this is gonna
leave me over here now
now the other thing that I don't know I
don't know, see that's where I died
because the floor collapsed now I don't
know if i was supposed to go that way
like was I supposed to go that way am I
just not supposed to ever go where
something tells me I can escape because
otherwise I was gonna die to the monster
so I was being routed. *monster gurgle roar* Yep it's just like that, huh? Just like that
ok so what's behind me
and it's coming after me but I'm not
supposed to go,
ah, shit. Well that's no good. Ah shit, what do i do *locked door sound*
oh dammit what do i do what can I go now
what's happening i thought i could go
here
uh oh. Am I gonna die?
uh oh
hey friend-o you wanna be friends?
I've got a peace offering
I'll chop off a piece of my butt and
give it to you because i don't actually
have anything, besides a lot of drugs
AHH!!  ok sorry whoa geez ok so try going a
left, how about this yeah,  this looks good so
that's not it but this is the way that
killed me, isn't it? looks like death
Its DEATH!
ooohhh, it wasn't supposed to kill me!
ooooooh, ahhhhhhh, okay so that wasn't supposed to
actually kill me, i was forsaken, oohhh wa-
was it because I was low on
health or something, ooh, we are in the pit
of bones now, do I want to know where
these came from, because once again I
want to comment on the illogicalness of
where we are, considering this was a mine
and now it seems like a castle dungeon
I mean I know I got knocked out back
there but i don't think I went far
enough to go into the catacombs under
France, I should probably keep moving, I think monsters
are still after me but the sheer
quantity of bones is very concerning in
the fact that they're using it as
carpeting is just a little disgraceful
disrespectful
oh, I- I can open that, can I? "The
disfigured man carried me all the way
down here and lock me up inside that
filthy old cell, was I supposed to wait
for someone? i should have left the
island when I had the chance."
your gosh damn darn right, you should of
not that you had a chance ya didn't
really have a boat, I mean I guess you
could have gone back instead of going
further deep down into the mine like a
fooool, so now we have what, more bones
good god it's an endless stream of bones
where else am I supposed to go? Is my friend
Boney gonna pop up out of here? gonna
teach me to "B" to blow, again? I don't
know
ok, hmm, I don't like this
me no likey, but me going
SEPTIPLIER IS STILL AWESOME
I don't like that, I don't like that, I
just played, RE77 and, only bad things
came out of a woman crying in the
distance
oh boy, yeah that ain't good
it's a, ooh, what the frick just happened to me?
well I don't know, but something did,
is there someone in there? Hello just cry
2 times if you're in trouble, (meeh)
I can't tell, sounds like a long, can't see anything
ok, so I don't see a way through
everything is locked up and there's no
doors, aah, here we go
I stand corrected, whoo it's quiet here,
why am I here
what am I doing, why am I doing it
where did I come from? where did I go
ok, ok, I feel like a rat in a maze and
i'm just being led around like a stupid
but ok!
shit, alrighty then, this is gotta be, frick,
sassafras, so many going backs, oh there,
ahh, how did I miss that why was that
there? all the places to put this, you
can only get to it if you had magical
powers
let's see were relying on, then they're
making me come through, they counted on
me finding that barrel of goo down in
the mush, aah shit, there I go going off
on my tangent and boo, heey
are you crying lady? I don't think
you're fun, don't think you're
gonna help me, I'll think i'm supposed to
fall down here, anybody got any food?
Oh good, I was hoping for a tasty juicy
leg, "the melody keeps ringing in my ears
long after the needle comes to an end
as if my mind thirst for more i know now
how this will end but first i will need
to have a word with everyone they are so
eager to hear by story"
oh, is this why everyone has been turned
into bones?
ah good great maybe you freed them from
the curse of the skeleton living inside
them
did you know you all have a skeleton
living inside you
how cool is science or biology, whatever,
how cool is that creepy fact? ok
oh, this is where i am now, ok, ah good
year old kebabs, there we go,  i keep
forgetting that I i fill up on the magic
juice definitely a lot more than I do
anything else so all right time to go
say hi to crying lady
hello ok.......
* unsure markimoo *
* startled markimoo *
what happened, ooh, hiii how are you, what
are you doing? woh, what are you doing?!
(what am i doing)
what are you doing, I'm coming over there
( ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) oh please mark)
oh that's not what I wanted to do, was it?
ooh,don't think I was supposed to do
that I don't think I wanted to free you
I don't trust me if you're the only
living thing in a sea of bones, i kinda know who the culprit is, alright then,
( fuck this shit im out )
oh shit this is bad, i thought this -
thought this was leading over to her
heh heh heehh, ok just empty cells
alrighty then don't mind me
I just freed you just stupid oh hello is
this way I was supposed to go without
falling like an
ooohhh, so scary! okay random guillotine
jump-scare I guess is better than a bear
trap you wouldn't think there'd be any
bear traps lurking amongst these
skellingtons, would ya? oh you're dead
okay good...heh i mean not good for you but
good for me because I don't want to deal
with the living, "is there no end of this
darkness? are we alone?
where is everyone? why has he left me
alive?
this place is calling me, I can feel it,
finally my mind is at rest." your mind is
at rest when the floor is bone
okie dokie then whatever you say mr. or
miss whoever you may have written that
i'm not entirely sure who
oh no oh no
( Just be silent and maybe she wont here me, fuck commentary )
oh she's gone oh she's gone
oh she's gone
OOH no, oh no (x5) I got
nothing else to say besides oh no becauz
bad..shit's bad yo i mean she's gonna be
stalking around the halls now
okay well you know maybe I'm maybe I'm
operating under the wrong assumption
maybe she's actually good maybe she's
gonna be super kind to me maybe
everything's gonna be great! * wishful thinking *
we're gonna have a fun time and swap
stories braid each other's hair, steal
each other's boyfriends... i dont know, i don't like
that. where could she have gone?
(groaning scaresly) eughh don't like that.. euughh
yeah i know i'm a big bitch, shut up!
something about women just terrifies me
yeah I can't talk to him I just freeze
up, what happend to my kebab?
give me my kebabs I need health real baaad
-groaning- ok, -girl scream-
*very confused mark face*
ok, alright let's not do, whhoaaeyy, she' s coming after MEE!!!
I DIDN'T THINK SHE WAS STILL STANDING THERE
close it!
ahhh! it fell Off!
Ahhh, shitty dicks
oh I'm fucked
waahhhh
Mrrrrrrrrrr
ahh, that's not good *girl screams* *Imitates the girl's scream* i know, right? life's
horrible. Does that mean she's chasing me?
okay, alright, okay so far so gooo, Oh back to
technology, huh?
not yet but we gotta find a way to open
this douche
ok so how do we open, ooh, this is a
hidey-hole, good hidey-hole
oooohh waaahh * imitates ' down with the sickness '*
is that what your trying to do? you need to go
deeper in the throat to be able to sing
that song, but wait, THIS IS NOT A HIDEY-HOLE
Oh God, aah, oh fack! i thought it waz, fuck does
that? noo I thought it was a hidey-hole
it was just a pillar of boxes and i was
all around the wrong side like an idiot
now i'm all the way back here because
the lovely save mechanic system is
awesome i did it again i did it again
why is that like that? why is that like
that? I wonder how many of their
playtesters just took a dive, or am i the only one?
ok I'm back to where I need to be and I
hear a save point somewhere over here
I just don't know if I can get to it. I
don't know if it's gonna be kind to me
like that, i don't think it is.. i don't
think it wants to be kind to me like
that i think it wants me to survive and
not die like an idiot because apparently
one hit from this lady is good
okay, so she's gonna come down this hallway
okay there she is ok so then we're just
gonna skedaddle around not mess with her
at all
Chobani? no brand deals in this one, so i
gotta find a way I think I've gone
around i think i got some hidey-holes
over here but gotta find something that
can.. oh come on, ya kidding me? there's gotta be
something over here
eh what is that, did i do something?ooh what did that do? i dont know what that did, but maybe, ooh
did that open the door
could it really be that simple? i dont know where she is,
can you scream for me?
so I know where u is.. okay (x4), so far so
Goo, can i block that off?
get (x6), *stange baby noises*  ok here we go
wow look at that, who the hell built this
down here, huh?
okay I'm gonna go back because i know
there's a save point around here somewhere i
heard the static! there's gotta be one
right?
also why? man someone's been slacking on
the cleanup duty after these cremations
because uh, there... no time for that
it's got to be a way to get to it over
here or something because otherwise I'm
going to be very pissed because I
couldn't find it and that's oddly
punishing if I can't find the save point
that was a big artistic rendering of a
vagina, awww, that's a trap!
oh that's a trap! (x2)
oh that's... hellooooooo? who's there
that's such a trap, its a trap, its a trapie trap, i know a
trap when i see it!
ok.. trAp!
ohhh it's not a trap. oh it's the opposite
of a trap. it's exactly what i, gaahh, fuck You!
ughhhhhhh,  ♫ eat 10 Dicks! (x2) where are
the rest of you, sacks of shit? ♫ okay
so far so Gooo, just don't trap me
ah there you are, bear traps! can't
believe I have to be so minutely aware
of them
"The man just keeps dancing endlessly
inside my head without mercy
I can't take it anymore and yet here i
am still waiting for words to fill the
next lines." i think that means you're out of your mind, i saved!!! and yet it's not
time to end the episode just yet
ooh, hello down there, well that's
convenient for dumping bodies
ok so this, which was obviously a trap
and I still say it was a trap because of
the bear trap... what was going to say? I have no
idea i was trying to complain, don't mind me
I'm just complaining that's me, Mr.
complain boy
hello! that almost killed me, thank you
alright why d'this this remind me a legend of
zelder? alright goodbyeee! boink, helloo? hello
goodbye?
anybody home? you are a thing.. *grunting noise*
that's so inconsi-  you can't throw these in - oh, you can. but it didn't work before
so why did it work this time?
physics system being all inconsistent
and bullshit! okay maybe I'm just getting
weak or maybe i'm just getting stronger
you never know ok so there's gotta be a
way to get up, right?
I imagine because they put so many boxes
and in such wonderful stacking shapes
i'm guessing that I need to stack and/or climb just like that
okay, hip!
ok..ah! something got in my eye!! aaahh! oh god like a
bug just flew right in my eye
holy shit, AHHH! wow I don't know what the hell
just went in my eye because it's not
like there's a swarm of gnats flying
around my face but holy shit did a
spider drop from the ceiling and land
in my eye?
alright anyway don't mind me just
getting emotional about this game so
emotionally invested
yeah oh wait no.. i'm supposed to go up here? is that
what I'm supposed to do, eeh
ok so what now? ok
oh well that's good, that's awfully nice
so I need to drag another sun'bitch up
here we just take this sun'bitch n' put it
there. habita hooski habita booski! I'm
uppy!
okay, anybody else? anybody else wanna
tango? why did I suddenly start crouching?
that was weird
*strange tongue noise* I don't know if I'm supposed to be
up here
oh well that seems safe, okay byeee! thanks
for the help!
right on my way. ah, good at least I'm
lighting my path so that all the monsters
will be able to follow me and murder me
and know exactly where I go and be able
to follow me all the way back home
i don't trust that, all right so I don't trust
that direction at all because that's
back towards where the lady was, as pretty
as she probably is- i see, i see you maybe I could
use this to break it in
see! it didn't work that time! eh there
we go. kebab! comeback, comeback kebab
anything else
okay so are we good here? oh god dammit
of course that's going to be not the way
i'm supposed to go
alright then back this way back towards the
lady.. who cares what's in that weird
castle that someone built underground?!
let's go straight down this hallway
it's definitely comforting, mmm, bones
it's the sign of the woman
dunno where she is but, she's close by
mmmkay
oh another save po-  another save point?! whoa oh
no this one's not powered, oh i gotta find
a way to power it
well that's inconvenient, thank you for
that, so where's the power supply? oh
i'm outta stamina
where's the power supply? there somethin' through
here? a lot of cables okay, there's one
is there something else I gotta do? oh it needs two, ok this is dead
well where am I gonna find one of those
why didn't I just put them in my back
pocket from the start? ooh, i can see outside!
and what is it pumping in? water? maybe?
for a steam engine of sorts? I don't know
alright gotta go hunt it down because
obviously it's not here
damn i'm not going to be able to save
and then somehow i know i'm gonna die
I just have a funny feeling. okay right here we
GoooOOo just want to sAaaave oh! thank you
oh, good! yeah, get out of here! (x2) *high pitched grunting noises* okay got
it
ehh damnit there we go
ok kebaaabs, finally I'm gonna be back to
full health
that's probably something under there
still I just can't reach it, is it a kebab?
ah, shit dude
ok want to get it, well you fucking
kak, well I'm building a fort under
there
god dammit, ok fine, fuck you physics!
alright, "with holy prayer i gaze of the
starry sky pure sacred lights and
children of the night
banish all darkness and grant us light
last there is no hope left we are
condemned forever walk in the shadows we
feast upon the forbidden fruit in our
despair our prayers now forever echoing
like drops of ink in a bottomless sea."
well that was beautiful, but what did it mean?
what does it pertaining to in your
current situation? your current
predicament of death?
man I don't know what happened to these
people but it has something to do with
this material that they refine to get
this energy source that I've got
carrying with me, like something in it is
either evil or mutating in some capacity
but i'm not sure which or how, boink! but
doesn't matter because I'm finally gonna
be able to save, habooski!
ah there we go, so that is all the time i
got for this episode here, i will
officially stop ragging on the save
mechanics, you know  i am playing the
game and I do enjoy the game it is very
good and it is quite scary like that
lady down there that was a really nice
touch and I bet she's horrifying when
you get up close, not that i saw her,  she kinda stabbed me up the butt so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see youuu.. in the next video
Buh-bye!!
Oh